left on the seven day free trial of the
qurani app and it exceeded All my
expectations alhamdulillah I was worried
that was an overrated product that's
we tried it what was the system you can
build a habit with the Quran by seven
day free trial promises no credit card
details required at all download it and
see what time it is
in the name of Allah the most merciful
the very merciful it seems like it's
official from his Andrew Tate's personal
social media brothers and sisters hats
off to him I mean I don't have a hat so
hoods off to him subhanallah he as
inshallah become a genuine high value
man brothers and sisters from his
account I'll just click a reader I want
to keep this very video very short it
said the following love of Allah is the
power of the heart the sustenance of the
heart the light of the heart his quoting
and then the next one he says this is
why I'm a Muslim any Christian who
believes in good and understands the
true battle against evil must convert so
be patient indeed the promise of Allah
is true Quran Chapter 30 verse 60. this
is from his social media platform I
checked many people and they said it is
actual social media platform that he has
that he's not banned from
it seems like it's official there is
evidence there and we saw previously
that he was praying we asked Allah to
keep him firm and on Muhammad hijab's
podcast we will find out more inshallah
keep tuned for that that's all I have to
say brothers and sisters and we praise
Allah
says your people come to Islam say his
praise and ask for repentance brothers
and sisters we ask Allah to forgive his
past sins and turn it into all good
deeds brothers and sisters inshallah it
seems like his official may Allah keep
him firm and based on that not just
undertake many many rivers and convents
who come to Islam they are left with
nobody promises it's a trophy shahada
and they're gone let's make sure that we
look after rivers to our government
going through so many issues as well at
salahplus.com with our organization we
help you to learn the Salah step by step
we can come out to you and teach you as
well and get a free guide to prayer mat
that's all I have to say inshallah Abu
Andrew Tate it looks like here may Allah
keep him from inshallah and make him
amongst those who strive for the dean of
and to make his book and his Kalam to be
the highest till next time